if you want to hear about what the
wendigo did in another stephen king
novel after the events of pet cemetery
then stick around to the end of this
video
hello and welcome to horror history my
name is professor sisi's world or
whatever the heck you want to call me
today's lesson is about the wendigo the
ancient creature that haunts the cursed
burial ground beyond the pet cemetery in
ludlow maine
stephen king's wendigo is based off of
an algonquian mythological creature but
in the novel it is attributed to a
different native american tribe located
near eastern canada and the northeast
united states known as the mikmaq tribe
which is spelled like this in the book
probably a reflection of how judd
crandall might have pronounced it
this was a burial ground who's burial
ground
big mac but this is how it's spelled in
real life
here are a few pronunciation videos that
i found mick mook
okay so now i know how a robot would
pronounce it but let's try to find the
human version
meek mac mcmahon
so the wendigo legends told of a huge
bipedal creature around 15 feet tall
some versions of the legend tell them
more human-like form while others ski
more beast-like but all seem to have a
few features in common they're extremely
thin from starvation to the point where
you can see their skeleton poking
through the skin all eugenia cooney
style or even wasting away to the point
where the skeleton is just exposed they
typically have a stag's head and antlers
often
claw-like hands a wretched smell of
decaying flesh and patches of fur
stained with human blood this is because
the legend is told as a metaphor for
greed consumption and starvation in
times of famine as a way to scare away
tribesmen from taboo ideas such as
cannibalism
some versions of the legend tell of
humans who were overtaken by greed
turning into wendigos or in the case of
pet cemetery those who came into contact
with the wendigo would become cannibals
let's explore the life of the wendigo as
depicted in the universe of stephen
king's novels
[Applause]
the first mention of the wendigo dates
back to pre-1600s when the creature came
across the mikmaq burial ground in
ludlow maine the wendigo used its
demonic powers to curse the ground and
the tribe soon discovered that any
corpse buried there would be brought
back to life by the wendigo
those who have witnessed these
reanimated corpses claim that they can
understand some truth behind the
stereotypical depiction of a zombie in
popular culture because the corpses
would come back as a shell of their
former selves with evil intentions to
flick physical and psychological harm to
all of those that they came in contact
with
including the consumption of human flesh
the micmac tribe came to understand this
new dark power that pulsed through their
resting place and abandoned it some time
before settlers arrived in the 1820s
what i would have done if i were them is
forget about all this cannibalism stuff
just change my name to the big mac tribe
and open my own burger restaurant
mcmacdonalds and there's a guy just up
the road who'd loved to be the mascot
ludlow became a small agricultural
community so a main road was established
to send crops out to be sold on the
markets the wendigo continued to stalk
the woods on the north side of this road
and its insatiable hunger continued to
build at the very end of the 1800s and
into the early 1900s the road became
more of a truck route as automobiles
were becoming more and more prevalent
which made it a very dangerous place
with truckers seeing it as an open
stretch of country road to blow through
despite the fact that there were
families situated on that road
some say the wendigo had something to do
with the reckless behavior of these
drivers because it had some kind of evil
influence within a certain radius of the
ground that it soured
drivers have reported a sudden urge to
drive fast when crossing over into
ludlow and not being able to pinpoint
why
this led to an increasing amount of
deaths from pets who had wandered into
the road and been struck down by these
trucks for this reason the kids of the
town established a pet cemetery in the
woods
and i personally think it's no
coincidence that this location was
chosen just shy of the mcmac burial
ground
i'd guess that the wendigo's influence
manipulated these kids to choose this
location at some point someone climbed
over the deadfall on the edge of the pet
cemetery and ventured through the swamp
and into the cursed grounds to bury
their pets
it's not clear who was the first person
to bury a pet there but those who did
receive
some kind of curse from the wendigo and
they'd almost always end up showing a
friend or loved one the power of the
burial ground the animals who were
buried there would be revived by the
wendigo and come back with the stink of
the ground they were buried in and were
usually meaner or more violent towards
other small animals and sometimes humans
however reviving pets who met their fate
too early was not seen as a horrible
offense because they lacked the ability
to communicate with humans
so the psychological attacks were not a
factor it's just a good thing they
didn't bury scooby doo brian from family
guy garfield stimpy courage mouth
detective pikachu lucy even though he's
not technically a cat charlotte from
charlotte's web and for the love of god
the cat in the hat
by the time judd crandall's dog spot
died in 1910
a boy named stanny b had already
discovered the burial ground secret and
passed it onto judd
when spot was reanimated by the wendigo
and came back from the dead the next day
judd's father was hardly surprised it
seemed that he too
knew of the burial groans power although
it's unclear if that was from experience
or if he had just heard about it he
warns his son not to go back to the
cursed ground again
and judd agrees he keeps this promise
for many years until one fateful day
when the wendigo lures judd back to the
burial ground
spot lived on another four years after
that and despite a couple of small
incidents
was mostly the same despite being
horrifying to judd's mother
but the cycle continued for years and it
was mostly kept a secret by the town's
locals
at one point a man named lester morgan
tried to revive his prized bull hand
ratty it's not entirely known how he
managed to lug the massive corpse all
the way up to the burial ground on a
sledge but it is implied that he
received some help from the wendigo when
han ready came back his possession by
the wendigo was particularly nasty he
would charge it anything that moved
animals people even trees swaying in the
breeze to the point that his horns were
broken and his head was bleeding
lester had to put handwriting down once
again to spare any additional damage the
wendigo continued possessing animals
buried in the place beyond the pet
cemetery until 1941 where a young ludlow
man named timmy baderman
was killed during world war ii should
have stayed home and played apex legends
timmy my man
his body was sent back to maine for his
funeral but his father stricken with
grief buried his body
in the burial ground the first known
human burial since the mikmaq days
the wendigo brought timmy back and
possessed him to scare the townsfolk who
all believed that timmy was dead
people started to notice him walking
along the roadside with a blank look and
gossip of his return
spread faster than a shane dawson
conspiracy okay
maybe not that fast got a little carried
away there the wendigo used its
knowledge of everything that has
happened in the town to torment those he
interacted with divulging their most
embarrassing secrets and making horrible
threats to some of the women in town
timmy's father ended up going insane
from his undead son's constant torture
and burned down the house with both of
them inside the next major incident took
place in the 1980s over 70 years since
judd buried his dog spot for the first
time
judd had just befriended the creed
family who had moved in across the
street from him
when the family's cat was run down in
the road judd took lewis creed to bury
the cat in the mcmack burial ground
finally breaking the promise to his
father that he would not go back there
judd believed that he never meant to
show lewis the cursed place that the
power of the wendigo made him do it and
by introducing lewis to the soured
grounds he transferred the curse to
lewis's family
not long after the young boy gage ran
into the street and was killed
i mean freaking needed by an oncoming
truck a tragedy that judd felt he was
partially responsible for because he
showed lewis the burial ground the
wendigo has the ability to influence
those within a certain radius of the
cursed ground and for the next two days
it constantly puts ideas
about digging up gage and putting him in
the mcmac grounds into lewis's head
lewis sends his remaining family away to
visit his wife's parents in chicago
claiming that he needs to wrap some
things up at work before he joins them
this gives him the privacy he needs to
retrieve his son and take him up past
the pet cemetery and over the deadfall
towards the forbidden burial ground his
wife rachel senses that something is
wrong and travels back to maine on a
string of last-second flights but after
just missing the last flight she's
unable to get there on time
she talks on the phone with judd who
realizes what is happening and tries to
stay up and wait out for lewis hoping to
talk him out of this despicable act
despite not being tired at first judd
quickly starts to doze off and
recognizes that the wendigo is doing
this to him
to try to clear any obstacles in lewis's
path judd does everything he can to stay
awake but in the end
passes out before lewis arrives as lewis
approaches the cemetery the fog around
him goes into a swirl and encloses him
he feels
that the swamp around him is alive and
sentient when the mist clears louis sees
a pair of yellow grey eyes before him
a spirit with rotting teeth the curved
horns of a ram
and peeling flesh was laughing in the
distance before him as lewis trudged on
after that
the face floated before him at a
constant distance until it eventually
faded
back into the mist the frogs and insects
of the swamp go quiet
as a huge creature shakes the ground
with its footsteps and approaches lewis
a vile smell fills the air as the
monster gets closer to him
as it reaches its closest point lewis
looks up and sees the sparks of a pair
of yellowish eyes some
60 feet above him the wendigo knowing
lewis is headed to the mcmac grounds
lets lewis pass as it continues going
north as lewis continues he comes across
a massive claw-like footprint
and forces himself to believe that it
was something else to keep himself from
going insane
lewis buries his son in the cursed
burial ground goes home and goes to bed
during the night the wendigo goes ahead
and revives gage who kills both judd
crandall and rachel
lewis discovers their bodies in the
morning and goes crazy after seeing what
the monster had done to his wife
but the last sane thought that crosses
through his mind
is the image of the wendigo in the swamp
that previous night
as he heads up the forest path with
rachel's body lewis's physician's
assistant steve masterton sees him
disappear over the deadfall presumably
passing on the knowledge of the burial
ground once again to feed the wendigo's
insatiable hunger with a new set of
victims
it's unknown what happened to the
wendigo from then until almost 15 years
later in the summer of 1997.
actually it's not really confirmed that
the wendigo comes back at all but there
are many people who believe that an evil
deity from stephen king's novel the girl
who loved tom gordon
is in fact the wendigo from pet cemetery
i don't personally think there's enough
evidence to draw this conclusion but
there are some points that i find
interesting anyways
the story is about a nine-year-old girl
named patricia mcfarland who goes
missing while hiking with her mom and
her
brother on the appalachian trail in
eastern maine the area she first gets
lost in isn't very close to the woods
that the wendigo prowl and pet cemetery
but if you continue down the appalachian
trail it does continue to go towards
ludlow so it's possible that the wendigo
traveled this stretch of the woods after
destroying lewis creed's family
after getting separated from her family
and lost from the path tricia continues
down along the stream to try to find
some civilization
and she notices some disturbing signs
along the way like a tree that's been
slashed by some giant claws and a
decapitated deer
which is maybe the strongest evidence
towards this creature actually being the
one to go considering that wendigo are
most often depicted with a stag's head
the further into her journey she gets
the more the voice in her head
tells her that this thing is following
her at some point trish starts to
hallucinate some strange
images and it's not entirely clear if
it's real or if it's in her mind
she comes across a trio of robed figures
in the form of her history teacher her
father
and the god of the lost the creature
that has supposedly been following her
and watching her
its head appears to her in the form of
one of her fears during the journey a
swarm of wasps
after several days she finally makes it
out of the wilderness to a road and the
god of the lost comes for her
in the form of a bear-like creature but
she and the hunter who helps her scare
off the deity are never quite convinced
this is an actual bear and both seem to
have an idea in their heads that it's
actually something supernatural
it could be the wendigo or it could be
some wild creature that was revived by
the wendigo and is now being controlled
by it
personally i just don't see a lot of
strong connections between the two and
i'd have to say maybe they're
related entities at best just as the
wendigo in the algonquian folklore was
used to warn against taboo behaviors
such as cannibalism
the wendigo and stephen king's stories
warns against tempering with the natural
order of life in pet cemetery the
wendigo tempts a doctor who's lost his
son to defy nature to bring him back
after being unable to resuscitate one of
his patients earlier in the story
in this sense it's very similar to the
classic horror story frankenstein
because in trying to create life this
doctor ends up creating a monster the
wendigo represents
the taboo that line that should never be
crossed by any man
it is an evil force an embodiment of
those things that go against nature the
girl who loved tom gordon also contains
themes of man vs nature
or at least nine-year-old girl versus
nature but they're conveyed in a much
more positive way with trisha defying
nature
by overcoming seemingly impossible odds
to survive
so that wraps up today's lesson here on
horror history
your homework is to like this video and
let me know what your thoughts are on
the wendigo and the god of the lost in
the comments
are they the same are they related or
are there just similar themes that tie
them together i'll be looking forward
to your responses check out the video on
the left for 47 things you might have
missed in the 1989 pet cemetery movie
adaptation
and if you're a fan of stephen king
you're definitely going to want to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring that death bell for
notifications and i'll see you
in the next one assuming we both survive